Der Rasenfunk-Kurzpass. Acht Spieltage sind in der 2. Fußball-Bundesliga der Männer gespielt. Höchste Zeit mal wieder draufzuschauen und ein paar Fragen zu stellen. Jetzt hier im Rasenfunk-Kurzpass Nummer 181. Tja, und an wen will ich diese Fragen stellen? Mein Name ist natürlich Max Jakob Ost. Ich bin der Ed Genetzer auf Twitter und ich begrüße bei mir Pike vom 1912 FM Holstein Kiel-Podcast, einem der Podcasts, der schon seit seinem Bestehen eines der schönsten Podcast-Logos der deutschen Podcast-Landschaft hat. Hallo Pike. Also wirklich, ich bin großer Fan. Habe ich glaube ich auch irgendwo schon mal geschrieben, auf Twitter und so weiter, wer auch immer das entworfen hat. Weiß nicht, ob ihr das wart oder bekannte Freunde von euch. Richtig, richtig schönes Podcast-Logo. Musst du bitte weitergeben. Und ebenfalls mit dabei eine bekannte Stimme. Da werden jetzt Leute niederknien, dass sie ihn endlich auch wieder im Rasenfunk hören. Und nicht nur in einem seiner zahlreichen anderen Podcast-Formate bei meinem Sportpodcast, der eh Tobias Rieger. Da macht er unter anderem auch Hannover liebt, den Podcast Hallo, Tobi.
Okay, also Falco Götz, ich musste nachgucken, das war ja 2009.
Ich dachte nur, so war es. Ja, das war so damals. Auf Platz 1 haben wir ganz logisch unseren Trainer entlassen, um dann den großen Namen Falco Götz zu holen, um dann durch zu starten. Da hieß es ja immer noch damals der Hoffenheim des Nordens und so. Und damit sind wir ja mächtig auf die Fresse gefallen.
Um dann mal aufs Sportliche zurückzukommen, wo wir nicht so sehr im Trüben fischen müssen. Du hast es ja auch schon angesprochen. Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass wir vielleicht in 5, 10 Spieltagen komplett anders über Holstein sprechen, weil man schleppt hat auch diesen fürchterlichen Saisonstart mit sich herum. 0 zu 3 beim FC St. Pauli, 0 zu 3 zu Hause gegen Schalke 04. Im DFB-Pokal zwar weitergekommen, aber nach Verlängerung beim SC Weiche 08 und dann 0 zu 3 gegen Jan Regensburg. Also zack, 0 zu 9 Tore nach drei Spieltagen. Danach schien es sich für mich als Außenstehenden schon stabilisiert zu haben. Es gab zwar nochmal eine Niederlage, natürlich auch wieder mit 0 zu 3. Das scheint das neue Go-To-Ergebnis zu sein. Und gegen Hannover 96, da hatten schon andere in dieser Saison keine Chance. Wer genau aufgepasst hat, weiß, welch Mannschaft ich damit meine.
Das war aber auch ein Freakspiel, muss man dazu sagen. Also mit Rot nach 10 Minuten und so. Da haben wir ein bisschen Glück gehabt in Kiel, möchte ich gerne anerkennen.
Das ist natürlich völlig korrekt. Aber es schien mir so zu sein, Pike, als hätte sich eben Holstein stabilisiert. Also es gab dann zwei 2-2-2-Spiele gegen Düsseldorf und Karlsruhe. Es gab den Sieg gegen Aue, jetzt den Sieg in Paderborn, den ich persönlich nicht erwartet habe. Aber gut, was kann man schon erwarten in dieser zweiten Fußball-Bundesliga? Also es schien sicher stabilisiert zu haben.
Ja, eigentlich dachte ich das sogar schon nach dem Schalke-Spiel, denn das Ergebnis ließ sich schlimmer als es war. Da waren wir einfach unfassbar ineffektiv, aber wir hatten 24 zu 9 Torschüsse auf Kiel's Seite, Passquote 90 Prozent zu 80 Prozent, wir hatten 63 Prozent Ballbesitz. Also eigentlich sprach alles für uns, außer unsere Abwehr und Simon Thurodde, weil den haben wir da wirklich auch komplett alleine gelassen.
Klar, den kattet ihr noch nicht, da ist in der zweiten Liga noch ein unbeschriebenes Blatt.
Ja, ich glaube, das wird noch mal einer. Sollte man auf dem Auge beiten. Das Regensburg-Spiel war dann natürlich direkt wieder ernüchternd. 3-0, wobei man natürlich jetzt auch sagen muss, gegen Regensburg kann man anscheinend mal verlieren. Die Mannspieler spielen ja wirklich eine überragende Saison. Ja, dann das Düsseldorf-Spiel, eigentlich 3 Punkte, am Ende noch knapp den Ausgleich kassiert. 3-0-Sieg gegen Aue, war ein gutes Spiel von Kiel. Allerdings muss man auch sagen, es ist nur Aue. Und auch, sorry, wenn man es so sagen muss, die spielen einen grauenvollen Fußball diese Saison. Karlsruhe auch, hätte man gewinnen können, wieder durch doofe Fehler das 2-2 kassiert. Das 3-0 gegen Hannover, ein Spiel, finde ich, was man ein bisschen ausgrenzen muss von allem. Weil einerseits klar, die frühe rote Karte, selbst wenn man dann noch was versuchen würde, dann geht so ein abgefälschter Schuss noch rein, ein paar Minuten später. Also da läuft wirklich alles gegen einen. Und dann ist es natürlich superschwer, gerade wenn du unten drin stehst. Und jetzt endlich mal wieder ein Sieg gegen Paderborn, die zwar auch einer weniger waren, die wir dann aber auch eingeladen haben zum Gegentor durch einen katastrophalen Fehlpass von Finn Bartels. Zum Glück noch gedreht. Ich glaube, hätten wir das verloren, hätte der Baum auf jeden Fall gebrannt hier in Kiel. Aber so war das jetzt, glaube ich, für die Mannschaft, fürs Umfeld und auch für die Fans ein ganz, ganz wichtiger Sieg, um alles so ein bisschen runterzufahren.
Und wo, glaubst du, ist die Ziellinie für Holstein Kiel? In welcher Tabellenregion muss man eigentlich dem, was man hat, an Spielern und an Möglichkeiten einlaufen in dieser Zweitliga-Saison?
Ja, also ich bin da ja immer noch relativ demütig und sage, nach so einem Saisonstart plus dieser ganzen Ole-Werner-Sache, mit einem Klassenerhalt bin ich zufrieden. Das ist so mein großer Wunsch. Aber wenn wir am Ende irgendwie, glaube ich, so 8. oder 9. oder 10., was ich nicht für unbedingt unrealistisch halte, dann bin ich auf jeden Fall zufrieden.
Und das kann ja auch sehr schnell gehen. In der zweiten Bundesliga der Männer haben wir schon häufig genug erlebt. Und die Saison ist ja dann noch sehr jung. Aber Holstein, Kiel, da sind wir mal sehr gespannt, wie das in der Trainer-Sache weitergeht. Eine Mannschaft gibt es noch, über die wir sprechen wollen. Das ist der SV Sandhausen. Der liegt aktuell auf Tabellenplatz 16 und wurde bisher noch nicht besprochen im Rasenfunk. Zwei Siege, ein Unentschieden, fünf Niederlagen. Da schien es Tobi ganz, ganz schlimm loszugehen und wurde jetzt dann ein bisschen besser, wenn man sich das anguckt. Also unter anderem der letzte Sieg war da jetzt natürlich wichtig. Ich weiß gerade gar nicht, gegen wen hat Sandhausen gespielt.
Hannover 96 ist mir völlig unbekannt, die Mannschaft. Keine Ahnung.
Also wir haben es ja vorhin schon angesprochen. Da haben auch individuelle Fehler eine Rolle gespielt. Aber jetzt hattest du eben so einen so genauen Blick auf den SVS. Wie schätzt du die denn bisher ein?
Na doll fand ich sie nicht, muss ich ehrlich gestehen. Also in der ersten Halbzeit kam gar nichts von Sandhausen, hatte ich das Gefühl. Die hatten auch kein Interesse daran, irgendwie was zum Spiel beizutragen.
Ja, 31 Prozent Ballbesitz, ja.
Ja, also es war wirklich, macht ihr mal und ihr werdet schon irgendwann was Dummes machen. Mit der Einstellung sind sie da rangegangen, hat natürlich auch funktioniert, ärgerlicherweise. Zweite Halbzeit hat Hannover dann auch nicht mehr so viel gemacht und dann kam aber auch nichts von Sandhausen, hatte ich das Gefühl. Also spielerisch war das wirklich, das war wenig. Also die vorne liefen glaube ich Kate Deruehl rum und Charlie Benchop, was dann schon mit zwei Stürmern fast schon beeindruckend war, aber die haben halt auch nichts zum Spiel beigetragen oder sich Chancen ausgearbeitet. Also man wusste schon, warum die da stehen, wo sie stehen in der Tabelle und der einzige Sieg, den sie vor dem Sieg gegen Hannover 96 hatten, war halt auch gegen Erzgebirge Aue. Also auch das sagt dann natürlich schon irgendwie aus, wie diese Saison im Moment bei ihnen läuft. Und ja, ich weiß nicht, das ist nicht beeindruckend. Das nächste Spiel ist gegen Darmstadt, über die haben wir vorhin auch schon gesprochen. Das ist wieder so ein Ding, wo hinterher dann alle sagen, ach ja, Mensch, guck, jetzt haben sie gegen Darmstadt auch gewonnen. Und jetzt haben sie dann schon ihre 10 Punkte zusammen und sind da unten rausgeklettert, weil sie ja auch, dürfen wir nicht vergessen, den Trainer gewechselt haben oder beziehungsweise die Trainer, Kleppinger und Kulowicz, haben das ja zusammen gemacht. Die haben sie dann rausgeschmissen nach dem siebten Spieltag, natürlich vor dem Spiel gegen Hannover 96, damit dann der neue, altbekannte Trainer Alois Schwarz gleich mit einem Sieg starten kann. Super Geschichte, ist ganz, ganz toll mit Sandhausen dieses Jahr.
Also Alois Schwarz war schon von 2013 bis 2016 Trainer beim SVS 108 Spiele, stand er an der Seitenlinie, ist eigentlich derjenige, mit dem meisten Spielen, nach ihm dann Kenan Kocsak und Uwe Koschinath. Das sind, glaube ich, die Namen, die wir alle auch noch so, zumindest so dunkel im Gedächtnis haben bei Sandhausen. Pike, was ist dein Eindruck vom SVS? Es scheint ja, also wird eine Zähl-Saison, ist jetzt aber nicht so die komplett spannende Vorhersage bei Sandhausen.
Genau. Ja, ich fand immer noch, dass die Entlassung von Koschinath damals irgendwie ein Fehler war. Das hat halt irgendwie gepasst und der hat echt eigentlich immer das Beste aus Sandhausen rausgeholt. Ich finde, eigentlich der Kader von Sandhausen ist gar nicht so verkehrt. Also allgemein Sandhausen immer mal mit Transfers, wo man sagt, wie machen sie das eigentlich? Also jetzt einen Pascal Teströhrt von Aue geholt, einen Ritzmeier von Barnsley, Gaudinho von den Young Boys Bern, der ja auch bei vielen Vereinen irgendwie auf dem Zettel stand. Also die haben öfter mal Transfers, wo man sagt, okay, warum geht der Spieler jetzt zum Sandhausen? Finde ich immer ganz spannend, deren Transferphasen. Aber spielerisch, ja, ich will nicht sagen, da fehlt ihnen die Mittel, weil die haben sie gefühlt eigentlich. Aber offensiv sind sie halt auch nicht kreativ. Also sie haben halt, ja, eine Ruelle und jetzt ein Band-Shop, da weiß man halt auch, was man da kriegt, wenn man die da vorne stehen hat. Gut, ein Test-Rid noch, der ein bisschen kreativer ist, aber an sich alles drei diese klassischen Abschlussstürmer aktuell. Also auch jetzt nicht schwer zu verteidigen, glaube ich, wenn man da so ein bisschen das System raus hat. Und das ist, glaube ich, so ein bisschen das Problem, dass ihnen da so die offensiven Lösungen fehlen. Ansonsten finde ich, ja, Sandhausen könnte weiter oben stehen, auf jeden Fall vom Potenzial, aber das rufen sie halt nicht konstant ab.
Gut, dann lassen wir es dabei auch bewenden und blicken auf Sandhausen mal irgendwann anders. Genauer, es sei noch der Vollständigkeit halber erwähnt, dass wir noch weitere Trainer-Entlassungen bzw. Trainerwechsel in der zweiten Liga haben. Ingolstadt, da wurde sowohl Trainer Roberto Petzold als auch der technische Direktor Florian Zehe entlassen. Vor dem Schalke-Spiel war das schon bekannt geworden. Und auch Aue hat sich in einer typischen Erzgebirge-Aue-Art von Spielewski getrennt. Ich weiß nicht, habt ihr eine Meinung zu diesen frühen Trainerwechseln, Tobi, in Anführungszeichen, aber die Art und Weise, wie das kommuniziert wurde?
Ich müsste lügen, wenn mir das nicht bekannt vorkommen würde. Aber das insbesondere mit Aue, ich gehe mal davon aus, du spielst darauf so ein bisschen an, war schon, ich hatte das Spiel irgendwie im Vorbericht gesehen, wo der Präsident sich dann geäußert hatte. Und nach dem Spiel war es dann schneller vorbei, als man gucken konnte. Insgesamt ein bisschen unangenehm, das Ganze zu betrachten von außen, ja.
Also so direkt mit Schlusspfiff sinngemäß war dann die Entscheidung nicht nur intern, sondern auch extern verkündet. Ich glaube, das ist das größte Problem, dass man das dann einfach direkt nach einem Spiel macht. Pike, hast du einen Take dazu?
Ja, also den Präsidenten von Aue, den kennt man ja nun schon durch seine Aktion, eine sehr spannende Personalie. Sportlich, muss ich sagen, bei Sandhausen konnte ich es nicht unbedingt verstehen, weil wie gesagt, da ist ja wirklich noch alles drin. Ehe so früh noch in der Saison, alles sehr eng. Bei Aue muss ich wirklich sagen, kann ich es verstehen, weil der Fußball wirklich, wirklich schlecht und nicht zweitligereif war. Muss man leider knallhart so sagen. Und deswegen kann ich es da verstehen, dass da die Reißleine gezogen wurde. Wie ihr schon sagtet, wie es kommuniziert wurde, das kann man, glaube ich, unkommentiert stehen lassen. Das spricht für sich.
Ja, das stimmt allerdings. Zu Ingolstadt habe ich noch ein Zitat rausgesucht von Peter Jeckwert, dem Vereinschef von Ingolstadt. Er sagt zu der Entlassung, wir hatten irgendwann das Gefühl, irgendetwas stimmt nicht, trotz der drei bösen Klatschen gegen Darmstadt, Bremen und St. Pauli. Hatten wir die Hoffnung, dass wir das Heimspiel gegen Düsseldorf positiv gestalten können. Nach dem 0 zu 1 gingen die Köpfe runter und es kam keine Reaktion mehr. Danach hatten wir das Gefühl, einen neuen Impuls setzen zu müssen. Und wenn ich jetzt irgendwelche anderen Namen genannt hätte, hätte man das auf jede andere Entlassung setzen können. Das ist einfach das kleine One-on-one, warum habt ihr euren Trainer entlassen? Und auf die Antwort, warum sie André Schubert geholt, hatte er dann auch die Antwort auf die Frage, warum André Schubert, ja, ich habe seit 2005 mit ihm Kontakt und der Kontakt ist nie abgerissen. Gut, so läuft es halt auch noch im deutschen Profifußball.
Hatte er bei uns damals schon Ingolstadt im Kopf, deswegen lief es bei uns nicht.
Ja, das ist ja, das ging ja schon so vielen Trainern so, dass sie einfach schon Ingolstadt im Kopf, dann verliert man es. Ihr zwei, ich danke euch ganz herzlich für diesen Parforce-Ritt durch die 2. Fußball-Bundesliga der Männer. Ich kann nur sehr alle Podcasts empfehlen, die ihr sonst noch so tut und euch auf Twitter zu folgen. Pike von 1912fm als 1912fm-Kiel auch auf Twitter. Danke dir, dass du mal im Rasenfunk mit dabei warst.
Hat Spaß gemacht.
Das freut mich zu hören. Und Tobias Rieger, der Ad-Runner, Tobi, auf Twitter hört natürlich die MeinSportPodcast-WG sehr empfehlenswert. Danke dir, Tobi, dass du dir Zeit genommen hast für dieses schnöde Fußballprojekt hier. Das ist ja eigentlich viel zu wenig für dich, für das, was du kannst.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, das war sehr, sehr schön. Vielen Dank für die Einladung, Max.
Schön, dass du mit dabei warst. Danke euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Der Rasenfunk ist werbe- und sponsorenfrei. Auch dieses Format finanziert sich allein durch euch. Auf rasenfunk.de/supporterscluberfahrt ihr, wie man uns unterstützen kann. Vielen herzlichen Dank an alle, die das tun. Dann hören wir uns wieder in einem der nächsten Rasenfunk-Formate. Das nächste Datumstechnisch ist eine Schlusskonferenz zum nächsten Erstligaspieltag. Bis dahin macht's gut, bleibt gesund, passt auf euch auf.